hey guys dr. Berg here in this video I
want to share with you how to handle
excess urination at night okay so let me
give you a little background first
there's two conditions I'm going to talk
about one is diabetes insipidus which is
a good type of diabetes which blocks a
certain hormone okay which causes you to
dump all your fluids so this type of
diabetes is a person that's craving a
lot of cold water like ice water they're
just dumping tons of water they're
craving it and it's going right through
so they're peeing a tremendous amount
okay that's the two big symptoms with
this condition right here because that
condition blocks a hormone that is
controlling the retention of urine or
fluid in your body so there's a hormone
called antidiuretic hormone that's
supposed to hold the water and this
condition blocks that hormone so you
dump all the fluid okay
thus the relationship between diabetes
and your nation okay there's another
condition called diabetes mellitus
different situation that's a high sugar
in the blood okay so high sugar in the
blood what happens it spills over into
the kidney and into your urine and
wherever the sugar goes the water goes
so water follows sugar okay so you're
going to pee more with this because
you're going to have more sugar in the
year end okay same thing with the if you
not a diabetic whatever and you actually
crave sugar and you eat sugar you're
going to hold a lot of fluid it's water
retention so just realize that wherever
the sugar goes water will go - okay now
there's a whole bunch of pre-diabetic
states so I'm not saying that this is
just for diabetics there is a gradient
scale from hardcore diabetes all over
here to a pre-diabetic situation so it
happens one step at a time so many
people have pre-diabetes and they don't
even know it and it happens gradually
over time so there's a condition called
insulin resistance that's a pre-diabetic
State and that's just a problem with
insulin that person is going to
eventually turn into a diabetic so
there's an incident issue as well so
they're going to tend to have a problem
with fluids in general
and I found that if you can correct that
pre-diabetic situation you can greatly
help someone's urination problem at
night okay so even the derivation of the
word diabetes comes from the word that
describes urine passing out through a
siphon or a tube so it's basically the
word even comes from too much urination
just coming out of your body which is
interesting okay there are six things
you need to do number one cut out the
sugar so you have to start reading
labels read the labels and if it has
even one gram of sugar try to get it to
zero grams of sugar or less than one
gram that includes cutting out the
fruits the juices the alcohol the hidden
sugars in the grains like the breads
pasta cereal crackers you need to cut
that out okay why because that's going
to aggravate the problem with insulin
okay
so just start cutting it up alright so
then number two no snacking between
meals why because even if they're
healthy snacking does increase insulin
what we want to do is we want to lower
the insulin okay because people with a
pre-diabetic have a resting insulin of
five to seven times greater than a
normal person okay no snacking so so if
you're not snacking and you're hungry
you want to jump up to number four which
is more fat so you want to add more fat
with a meal fat is the only thing that
will not trigger insulin too much so it
kind of keeps insulin down so you can a
breach ease you can have peanut butter
avocado olives coconut oil some type of
fatty healthy fatty thing that will
actually allow you to go longer because
if you try to do this on a low-fat diet
you're going to be craving stuff you're
going to be so hungry you're going to
need a snack okay less meals so if
you're not hungry in the morning skip it
skip the meal and just do two males one
at 12 and when it's said six six o'clock
okay and then use add more fat to adjust
that all right next one five more
potassium foods that would
more large vegetables okay we want big
salads you can't eat the meat with the
salad you can have a shake with blended
like a kale shake if you want I have
videos on that but we need more
potassium why because potassium
decreases the need for insulin all right
and then lastly more B vitamins B
vitamins also decrease the need for
insulin so actually these two are really
important don't get the synthetic
version get some non fortified
nutritional yeast from the health of
store ok or at amazon.com make sure it's
non fortified take a tablespoon of
nutritional yeast it's going to be very
very important to do this so number one
cut out the sugar no snacks between
meals less meals like two meals maybe
three but no snacks between more fat
with the meal more potassium foods
vegetables avocados more B vitamins okay
from nutritional yeast if you did if
then average diabetic or pre-diabetic
did these things right here you would
see huge changes these are the most
important things and you just need to
try this for like two weeks and prove it
to yourself that it'll work because if
you're not getting up at night urinate
urinating just think about what your
sleep is going to be like okay and your
energy is going to be like getting up
every hour and the hour is a is a
nightmare and I will guarantee that the
people that have your nation problems at
night that I mean I've seen it so much
like and I can guarantee that you're
going to see a 1:1 relationship they
have a blood sugar issue they're always
doing something they're eating eating a
little bit too much sugar doing too much
alcohol snacking grazing at night have
many too many meals the meals are too
big sometimes doing low fat they're not
doing enough vegetables okay so I hope
that helped and I will see you in the
next video